nous ce soir david caron coordonnateur
de projets spéciaux au centre collégial
de l'alberta spécialiste des questions
énergétiques
edmonton bonsoir david caron bonsoir
alors comment expliquer ce prix négatif
sous la barre des 0 $ pour le pétrole
pour livraison en mai mais ce qui se
passe présentement c'est que la plupart
la production pétrolière a déjà été pré
déterminée est alors allé déjà sorti
deux temps si vous voulez l'aider je
reçois en chemin ils soient empreintes
de smara fini et de l'autre côté on se
retrouve avec une chute très important
de la demande à cause du corona virus
alors on est par exemple le transport
aérien qui comprend environ 7% de la
demande mondiale de pétrole était le
brasero alors qu'on a du pétrole de
trouville problème présentement c'est
qu'on ne peut pas de capacités
d'entreposer tout ce pétrole là alors
c'est comme si le pétrole présentement
devenait dans un environnement
économique un peu comme une externalité
c'est à dire un peu une pollution qu'on
veut se débarrasser plomb vous de payer
pour que quelqu'un vienne nous aider à
nous débarrasser de ce biais là ben oui
est ce que dans les faits il ya des
producteurs qui viennent payer des
acheteurs en ce moment mais il faut
nécessairement des producteurs donc
comme content qu'elle des gens qui sont
dans le transport alors l'idée c'est que
de la façon que les marchés pétroliers
fonctionne comme l'avait dit c'est un
peu des contrôles qui sont pas en
vigueur entre un producteur et un
acheteur alors ce qui se passe et que le
producteur s'étant déjà entendues avec
quelqu un qui était pour lui acheter de
la production un certain moment de dire
combien on s'est entendu pour des voix
si je te livre tant de litres de pétrole
à tel endroit à telle date
et lorsqu'il se passe c'est que dans
temps normal cela devrait se passer en
fait c'est que si on n'a pas vraiment
besoin du pétrole bondit de la capacité
pour l'entreposer mais c'est pas le cas
présentement
alors on retrouve par exemple en droit
pour nous toutes sortes d'histoires
comme quoi les bateaux sont les étoiles
et son paquet parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de les vider le même chose en
étant au détriment de plein de baril de
pétrole qui sont présentement prix et
qu'on n'est pas capable de livrer parce
que personne qu'il est vous hélas ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en particulier
puisse avoir fait la même chose pour
demain c'est que ces contrats futures là
pour mes vont arriver à échéance demain
c'est à dire qu'il faut pour les
clôtures et si vous voulez on
dix jours avant la fin du mois alors il
faut que toutes les contrôles demi soit
clôturée avant le 21 avril dont demain
alors il faut absolument que tout les
contrôles soient fermés non mais si on
se retrouve en plus avant des
spéculateurs qui entre dans le marché
ici donc des gens qui pourraient gagés
sur le fait que le prix du pétrole va
varier dans le futur ces personnes sont
dans des bureaux ils vont ils veulent
pas avoir de pétrole qui va pas aller
chercher du pétrole du physique à aller
chercher et c'est un présentement qui
affecte le marché c'est eux qui veut se
débarrasser de leur contrat et la seule
façon de se débarrasser de votre contrat
de livraison mais c'est l'exemple de
payer la personne de lui payer les baril
de pétrole qui vont arriver pour dire
les bretons avec son hd de quoi alors
cela dit c'est une anomalie parce que
quand on regarde le prix de juin ou de
juillet il ya encore un des prix même si
le même si ce prix-là décès oui
effectivement alors c'est pour ça qu'on
dit que c'est vraiment les contrôles de
mai qui sont problématiques
en juin on a quand même un prix qui est
relativement faible maintenant si vous
regardez les prix pour les contrats qui
arriverait en juillet en est où on a
encore un prix plus élevé 27 28 dollars
alors ils les contrôles existent pour
une plus longue période de temps et
c'est contre la il n'a pas encore la
crainte de dire on a du pétrole indices
pétrole physique dont on doit s'occuper
alors pour l'instant c'est petronas ont
ces contrôleurs sont un peu encore un
peu de valeur
pourquoi si on se retrouve dans cette
situation là et notamment en alberta où
le prix est de toute façon avoisine les
3 4 5 dollars au quotidien avec le
différentiel par rapport aux prix
américains
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à arrêter la
production parce que c'est loin d'être
rentable de produire du pétrole en ce
moment mais la question c'est à savoir à
quel point est-ce que c'est contre le
sénégal aussi présentement alors le prix
présentement ce qui nous indique se dire
si on devait mettre en place un nouveau
contrat entre un acheteur et un vendeur
c'est le prix que le marché donnerait
pour le nouveau baril pétrole mais en
tant que tel le contrat que le
producteur en alberta a déjà signé avec
un acheteur c'était pourtant amendé du
pétrole qui y seraient 25 30 voire 50
dollars le baril parce que les contrats
qui arrivent à échéance la honte et été
eni disons en décembre passé lorsque la
liberté voit quand même un revenu de 50
$ parce qu'on lui a garanti contre
n'était pour lui payer 50 dollars le
baril mais quand actuelle aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout été pris l'eau auquel
on pourrait faire le même qu'autres
alors faut par un peu la distinction
entre et contenant ici parce que c'est
sûr que si le prix du pétrole est
effectivement le contredisez on vous
levant 5 dollars je pense moquait un
producteur en alberta qui accepteraient
de signer un tel contrat au niveau de la
livraison se fait qu'à ce que viendrait
changer une aide du gouvernement fédéral
jason kenney dit aujourd'hui ça prend du
soutien c'est urgent pour l'industrie
mais en tant que ça dépend comment on le
croit encore une fois de trop de pétrole
sur l'avion on peut importe l'argent
qu'on veut donner aux entreprises
ça changera pas le fait que le prix du
pétrole est extrêmement faible et
conseille pour quoi faire avec ce
pétrole là ce qu'on peut faire par
contre ça serait de soutenir les pertes
potentielles que vont réaliser ces
entreprises là pour limiter les pertes
d'emplois mais en partie pour pour le
marché en soit le gouvernement peut
absolument rien faire un contrôle sur le
prix et sur la demande de pétrole on n'a
pas la capacité d'entreposer ces barils
à ici en alberta en attendant que le
prix remonte alors il ya de la
production qui est en place qui a déjà
été promise
mais maintenant la réalité c'est que si
le prix demeure aussi faible que ça
vient d'avoir 25 d'alors pour les
prochains mois mais c'est là qu'on va
rediscuter à maintenir les prix la
prochaine est une entreprise et par
conséquent tous ces emplois ne sont
liées à la production pétrolière david
caron vos explications était très clair
merci beaucoup
j'ai appris